science tells us at different ages we
are best situated for searching certain
achievements 18 is the best age to test
your brain's power and at 71 your
vocabulary is at its most expansive in
this morning's reporter's notebook we
reflect on something none of us has any
control over aging and how one birthday
causes many of us to stop and take stock
of our lives I turned 50 recently this
is a fact I could not avoid because
Facebook required all my friends to make
a comment the message was clear 50 is a
fact I must come to terms with but I
already have to accommodate my aging
eyes the lettering on my phone can now
be seen from space my hairs are tracked
like an endangered species
[Music]
when you have a midsummer birthday you
are aware of your mortality summer time
is like a life span you roll around in
the early days with hours to burn but
then the hands on the clock start to
spin at the speed of a propeller on a
biplane suddenly summer's over and you
wonder where the time went
still to drive the point home my family
gave me a bottle of Centrum silver
surveys do show that when people are
asked to assess how they're doing 50 is
the age when they feel the most blum
they're worried about retirement
adolescent kids are driving them crazy
or they've left and they miss them but
then things turn around
people get happier as they age older
people are less stressed are nourished
by personal relationships and feel
deeper gratitude we can nurture this
don't rage against the dying of the
light but exploit the perspective that
comes from age let each fruit be
harvested in its own season route Cicero
in his study of old age it's not by
strength or speed that great deeds are
done but by wisdom character and sober
judgment these qualities are not lacking
in old age but in fact grow richer so if
we must see this age as the first
dimming it should not be the twilight of
the setting day but like the moment the
lights start to dim before a movie a
sign of excitement to come we don't know
how the story will end but at least we
can buy the popcorn
that was a nice analogy did you feel
like Molly
Janet 50-round kick will stretch if you
can hit your pants up that high a lot is
available to you so you feel good some
people get freaked out at 50 it's the
first time I realized I probably won't
live another 50 but I think it's a great
age oh yeah no it is but there is a
culture of people who try to freak you
out at age 50 yes man those people
welcome to the club it's a good old club
too John